make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today on our beyond Omega level series
we're going to be discussing one of the
biggest threats that DC universes ever
faced the anti-monitor so as we always
do here we'll start by explaining the
ante monitors origin and then get into
his powers and his abilities so the
anti-monitor was created by Marv Wolfman
George Perez and Jerry Ordway
and made his first full appearance in
crisis on Infinite Earths issue number
six in 1985 but the ante monitors origin
has actually undergone some changes
recently so we'll look at the origin
story as it has stood for the last
thirty years then we'll get into how
it's been changed so the ante monitors
origin dates back to the creation of the
multiverse which started on the planet
Malta's home of the owen people back
before they became the guardians of the
universe now was there that a scientist
built a machine to show him the origin
of the universe now as you might expect
the experiment goes awry and the Machine
explodes and the universe is broken into
several splintered universes along the
way with an antimatter wave of course as
most of you guys know this scientist was
cronic now within the antimatter
universe slides the planet of cord which
would be home to the anti-monitor that
the anti-monitor quickly conquers cord
and the entirety of the antimatter
universe and also learned the existence
of his counterpart in the multiverse the
monitor and the two of them began to
fight for a million years before they
enter a sort of stasis for billions of
years after that
now the ante monitors origin was tweaked
a little in final crisis in 2008 which
revealed that both the monitor and the
anti-monitor
were creations of the over monitor which
sent a smaller monitor into the
multiverse as a probe to explore it and
it eventually split into two entities
the monitor which personified positive
manner and the anti-monitor
which of course personified antimatter
not even more recently Scott Snyder's
Justice League run has altered the ante
monitors origin yet again revealing that
the monitor in the anti-monitor are
brothers and that they along with a
third brother known as the world forger
are actually offsprings of a super
celestial known as Perpetua in the 6th
dimension which up until that point was
not known to exist and basically serves
as the highest plane of the multiverse
existing beyond the concepts of time and
imagination and accessible only to
perpetuate and her offspring and it's
also been said that if any of them were
to die they would be born again into the
sixth dimension so yeah his origin which
was already pretty complicated has
gotten even more convoluted over the
years but regardless on to what his
powers are and like many of the
characters that we cover in the series
his powers are basically everything he
possess
matter and antimatter manipulation super
strength near invulnerability and
reality-warping now with a character
this powerful we can only really get a
sense of how powerful he is
if we look at what he's done and because
the anti-monitor is so powerful he isn't
a character that's been used that often
since his introduction because bringing
him in too often kind of cheapens the
character so he's only shown up when the
stakes are exceedingly high now during
his first story or crisis on Infinite
Earths he not only kills Supergirl but
he defeats Superman without breaking a
sweat and that's significant because
we're talking about pre-crisis or Silver
Age Superman which is vastly more
powerful than his subsequent versions so
being able to beat him so handedly is an
impressive feat in and of itself but
that's not even the most impressive
thing that we've seen the anti-monitor
do during that crisis we also saw him
absorb the total energy of the
antimatter universe and also destroy and
absorb the energy for most of the
positive matter universe as well before
traveling back to the ending of time
where he fights a contingent of fifty of
Earth's most powerful heroes with enough
power to destroy an entire solar system
but they're unable to do any meaningful
damage to the anti-monitor before he
absorbs the energy of all of them which
gives him nearly enough power to remake
all of reality now it takes the power of
The Spectre one of the strongest
entities in the DC multiverse to fight
the anti-monitor to a draw and the fight
between the two expelled so much energy
that the entire multiverse was destroyed
giving way to a sealed universe going
forward after that the anti-monitor then
relocates the resulting earth to the
antimatter universe in an attempt to
destroy the only remaining remnants of
the positive matter that's left in
existence now eventually the
anti-monitor is defeated by the Superman
of Earth to Alexander Luthor of Earth
three superboy-prime and dark side when
he's punched into a star by Superman now
we can see just by looking at how many
insanely powerful heroes it took to
defeat the anti-monitor that he's a
ridiculously powerful entity and with
the number of universes that he's
destroyed he's almost certainly the
character with the highest kill count in
the history of DC Comics now following
the events of crisis we see the
anti-monitor in extreme moderation but
we can still see him pull off some
pretty insane feats including surviving
an explosion that could destroy the
entire galaxy defeat the guardians of
the universe and withstand an assault of
the combined forces of all the various
Lantern course without any ill effect
the new 52 version of the anti-monitor
is also able to wield the anti-life
equation and use it
coerce any being to do his will and is
able to unite the black racer entity
with the flash which he then orders to
kill darkside so yeah that is basically
the anti-monitor obviously a multiversal
threat so obviously well beyond Omega
level and like I said he hasn't really
made very many appearances but in the
few times that we've seen him we've seen
that he is ridiculously powerful but let
me know what you guys think and let me
know in the comments who you guys want
to see me cover next in future videos if
you guys are new here too comments
explained miss you guys with the
subscribe button to become part of the
Rob port if you guys want to see my
uncensored videos my vs. videos early
access videos all consecrated videos
might come up a preview show my my own
personal podcast that comes out a week
early live Q&A s if you guys want to win
Rob core rings make sure you guys head
over to patreon comments explained and
if you guys enjoy this video make sure
you drop a like that we'll catch you all
later purse we've got some new patrons
in our top tiers over on patreon comm
slash comments explained I want to give
a shout out to Jason see Austin s Austin
H Phillip and Austin B as well as Steven
Z Eagle F Joey M and Jeff are as well as
Genesis 916 as always we just usually
keep the last name - an initial it helps
you guys to maintain your anonymity some
of you guys were expressed concerned
about having like your first and last
name thrown out there for the world to
see I do not blame you for you guys who
have joined up as part of our patreon
tiers that are eligible for rob court
honor guard rings those whose rings have
been sent out you should already have
them if you're a new person who just
joined up and you've been part of this -
here for a month your ring will be
mailed out to you so I want to say thank
you guys for beatin patrons
[Music]
you